He-Man is back and he still has the power!
Now that "Masters of the Universe: Revelation"
is out on Netflix, many viewers will want
to look back at the original show for more
muscle-bound action.
We're here to catch you up on lore and anything
else you may have forgotten about.
When most people think of He-Man it's about
muscles, action, and the fights against Skeletor
to save Eternia . Each episode creates a new
conflict that sends the hero into battle to
help someone or keep the peace — but that
can't be all that the titular character does
with his time, right?
He-Man was eventually given an alternate identity
in the form of Prince Adam within the pages
of the comics.
This was kept a secret from many of the supporting
cast, so that Skeletor couldn't simply kill
his foe while he wasn't powered up.
But it also gave the character a weakness
and created some entertaining story moments
when Adam couldn't easily slip away to transform,
or had to make excuses to exit a battle so
his alter ego could help out.
During the classic show's episodes, viewers
are given a few small glimpses into Adam's
duties as a member of the royal family: attending
events like the joust, and watching performances
from Man-E-Faces and other entertainers, as
well as other small diplomatic outings.
When those duties aren't taking up his free
time, the Prince is seen training, or more
often opting to skip these lessons with Teela
to nap or enjoy other leisure activities.
For a series that takes place on Eternia,
everyone would be forgiven for assuming there
were no Earthlings in the story, but that's
not true.
The show sees its fair share of people from
the planet, mostly in the form of kids — as
we saw in the Christmas special.
However, a couple of members from the main
cast are hiding that secret origin as well.
Queen Marlena, He-Man's mother, was originally
an astronaut from Earth who was thrown off
course after meteors hit her ship, the Rainbow
Explorer.
This detour to Eternia was supposed to last
a few days, but after we are shown a flashback
of this in the episode "The Rainbow Warrior,"
she explains that love took hold instead.
This sequence might have meant more had she
not dropped a random, "back on Earth," line
during the joust earlier, but it's still an
intriguing revelation.
Marlena gets to show off her piloting skills
and save the day in this adventure, while
Prince Adam is stuck without his powers, temporarily
at least.
This means that Prince Adam is also half-Earthling,
and even he — as He-Man — is shocked to
see that it was his mother that freed them,
meaning it is unlikely many other than King
Randor knew much of her past as a captain
of the stars.
This is also the episode where Queen Marlena
not-so-subtly hints that she knows who her
son truly is.
"Adam, a mother always knows her own son and
what he is capable of doing."
His name is a cringe-inducing attempt at a
pun, but the backstories for the comics tried
to make "Man-E-Faces" more serious, giving
him the origin of a tortured actor, transformed
by one of Skeletor's potions and given split
personalities.
The character would make only two main appearances
and a couple of cameos in the show, leaving
more of an imprint with his gimmick than time
on screen.
He was originally going to pop in for a side
gag in the episode "Into the Abyss," but was
cut to help the tone.
Those who do recall Man-E-Faces remember him
as a hero, fighting alongside He-Man, or at
least are aware of his reputation as the greatest
actor in Eternia.
But in "The Mystery of Man-E-Faces," viewers
are also shown that he began on the wrong
side of the law, terrorizing people smaller
than him, even if he wasn't purely evil.
Man-E-Faces tells He-Man that these acts were
because others were afraid of him, fearful
of his abilities, and shunned him for this.
In his own words, this led him to be "cruel"
toward everyone and steal from them.
After a run-in with Skeletor and Beast Man,
who abused him for their own purposes, He-Man
and Teela helped free the future actor, and
Orko even gave Man-E-Faces his name.
Teela is arguably one of the most interesting
characters in the He-Man universe, but having
several changes made to her backstory and
altering the relationship she shares with
the group for various incarnations can make
it difficult to keep up with her.
In the original mini comics, Teela was a clone
of the Sorceress created by Skeletor, an element
that was probably inserted to help explain
the armor on the original action figure.
In other versions, Man-at-Arms is her biological
father.
There's also a theory that Fisto might actually
be her dad, and in the 1983 cartoon Duncan
adopts Teela and keeps the identity of her
mother a secret — which is revealed in the
episode "Teela's Quest."
Here, Teela gets a bit envious of Prince Adam's
relationship with Queen Marlena and sets off
to find out who her mother really is by seeking
the oracle.
Being a bit rash, Teela heads off to a dangerous
place by herself and runs afoul of Mer-Man
and a sea monster, but He-Man shows up to
help.
She goes through all of this and discovers
that her mother is none other than the Sorceress,
only to have those memories erased.
The knowledge is treated as an incredibly
important tidbit that she can't know, but
now He-Man is aware of it also.
This is brought up one other time in "Teela's
Triumph," where she temporarily assumes the
role of the sorceress.
Many viewers were not fond of Orko.
This could be because the character didn't
appear in the initial run of the toy line
— having been created for the cartoon.
Or perhaps it's because he typically played
the role of comedy relief.
He is the King's Royal Buffoon, after all.
Orko was a klutz, never really able to do
his magic correctly, often hindering the heroes
on their missions and constantly damaging
Man-at-arms' lab.
Somehow, he's still one of Prince Adam's closest
allies.
It isn't surprising that most fans were more
upset at the lack of Battle Cat in the live-action
film than not seeing Orko.
He's a powerful character – even if he has
trouble getting his spells to work properly.
As a Trollan, Orko possesses a mastery over
matter creation, his hat opens up into a dimensional
space where he can keep any number of items,
as well as an extra hand comes out of there,
and his teleportation powers allow him to
easily escape many traps.
His potent tricks do seem to work somewhat
better back in his home dimension, where the
laws of physics work differently.
There is a medallion that helps him as well,
but some of these points contradict themselves
as the show progresses.
More importantly, in "Creatures from the Tar
Swamp," Orko saves Adam and Cringer at a young
age, before they had their powers.
He-Man was originally supposed to wield a
battle axe back when he was in toy form, but
looking back now, he wouldn't seem right without
his Power Sword.
The "Masters of the Universe" toys also came
with two swords, and these had to be put together
to unlock Castle Grayskull.
In the '80s, however, shows came under fire
from parent groups and politicians alike,
prepared to blame much of society's ills on
the pop culture of the day.
As pre-emptive measures, Skeletor got a staff,
He-Man held back on his swordplay, and other
creative decisions were made to walk a tightrope
ensuring that the series could be kid-friendly,
yet still be appealing to the older crowd
as well.
"Teela!
Could you put your finger here for a second?"
He-Man barely uses his fists, let alone his
sword, and most of his aggressive actions
are levied against large monsters or robots.
Whenever the hero is dealing with humanoid-type
characters, his tactics become more about
subduing the enemies.
His preferred method is usually to throw large
rocks, or simply to pick the perpetrator up
and toss them.
Public Service Announcements — often shortened
to PSAs — have a long and complicated history
that can arguably be traced back to the Civil
War.
Filmation is often mentioned for modernizing
these messages with their work on "Fat Albert
and the Cosby Kids" and "He-Man."
The latter almost had to have these little
lessons due to how closely parents related
the show to violence, and the producers tried
hard to balance out the program.
Running 130 episodes, the show covered a lot
of ground with these messages, so it makes
sense that they don't all land quite right.
A few are uncomfortable and others are just
plain silly.
Consider, for instance, the PSA that had Ram
Man telling kids not to run their heads into
things.
"Trying to use your head the way I do's not
only dangerous; it's dumb."
Others were a bit more serious, and included
a wide variety of pertinent topics, such as:
inappropriate touching, ageism, judging people
based on their appearances, not taking shortcuts
for wealth and power, accepting failures and
learning from mistakes.
Within the episodes themselves were some solid
examples of needing to have faith and that
even He-Man can lose his confidence, which
the creators say paid off based on stories
fans told them years later.
It's no secret that Filmation was banking
on "He-Man and the Masters of the Universe"
to help put the company on the map, and to
make sure everything worked out the way they
wanted it to, costs had to be kept low.
This pride in an American-made show kept under
budget led to cuts all around, with voice
acting and animation taking the largest hits.
As anyone who watches the show can hear, various
small characters have familiar voices, and
zoomed-in shots frequently take the place
of actual animation, as reused assets, rewound
motions, and replayed sequences became the
norm.
Speaking of cutting corners, the character
of Orko originally had another name, Gorpo,
which can still be heard in some Portuguese
translations of the show.
This late alteration seems to come from a
financial standpoint instead of a creative
one, because if the character had a large
letter G imprinted on his clothing, it would
be harder to flip footage of him and make
scenes look different without having to redraw
the floating magician.
This brings into question how many other changes
might have happened all in the name of saving
a few dollars, even if Orko is the better
name.
Most folks don't think of great writing or
production value when recalling "He-Man and
the Masters of the Universe," but the truth
is that the program had some incredibly skilled
behind-the-scenes talent.
Not only was there a tremendous group of voice
actors who brought the characters to life
– many of them having to talk to themselves
in a majority of the scenes – but other
voices had to be filled in by one of the founders
of Filmation, Lou Scheimer.
Additionally, his wife and daughter even lent
a hand, making it quite a tight-knit group.
The energetic music was handled by Haim Saban
and Shuki Levy , giants with stellar resumes
in the world of children's programming.
Behind the scenes was Bruce Timm, now known
as the mind behind some of DC Comics' greatest
animated projects.
One of his earliest gigs was as a background
artist and designer for "He-Man," while he
was also given a chance to work with the mini-comics.
Some of his fellow comic book brethren were
present to help on scripts, with Paul Dini
and J. Michael Straczynski working on the
show early in their careers.
"Star Trek" scribe D.C. Fontana contributed
an episode featuring the origin of Battle
Cat as well.
Even if children's show trappings restricted
what could be done, no one could ever say
that He-Man didn't have a wealth of talent
behind him.
"Masters of the Universe: Revelation" is attempting
to give fans a proper continuation to the
'80s cartoon, but it's not the first time
this has been attempted.
Although rarely remembered, there was an attempt
at a direct sequel that mutated into its own
strange oddity.
Sales for the toy line had begun to decline
drastically by 1986, and it was evident that
the franchise needed some sort of rejuvenation.
This came in the form of a redesigned set
of toys, which would require a new show to
help sell them like last time.
Enter "The New Adventures of He-Man."
This show uprooted Adam from Eternia, placing
him instead on the ultra-high-tech planet
Primus.
Leaving most of the cast behind, Skeletor
did tag along to remain his nagging nemesis.
This near-complete rehaul of He-Man featured
a protagonist that didn't look like the musclebound
warrior kids were accustomed to seeing, as
well as one of the worst designs for Skeletor.
Other than the upgraded visuals, almost everything
else was worse, and the show is often remembered
— if at all — as the weakest of the franchise.
Somehow, "New Adventures" ran for 65 episodes.
There were rumors of a second season that
would send Adam back to Eternia, but instead
the '90s led He-Man into relative obscurity.
With "Masters of the Universe: Revelation,"
perhaps it is finally time once again for
He-Man to have the power.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
animated shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.